[Music]
my relationship to the natural world was
largely fostered through my grandparents
who owned a farm in Idaho we would go
there every summer and we were free to
roam and play in the forest and hangout
but I still didn't necessarily think I
wanted to be a scientist it wasn't until
I got to understand the creative part of
science that it wasn't just about
memorizing like facts in a textbook
that's what really made me realize oh
wait actually this is a creative process
and I love it my name is Kristen Roy I
am an assistant professor at Colorado
State University
and I am the co-director of a project
called the bird gene escape project
the goal of the bird gene escape project
is to track hundreds of the most
critically threatened Birds
all kinds of birds are part of this
project from tiny songbirds like the
willow flycatcher to my favorite the
charismatic burrowing owls
I think it's amazing that over half of
the birds that are in North America
actually leave during the winter months
and go somewhere else and spend you know
the majority of the year actually not
here
birds migrate south in the winter in
search of better weather and more food
and they migrate back north in the
spring in search of better habitat for
breeding the main mystery with birds is
where do birds migrate the ability to
attract migratory birds has been a huge
challenge for centuries one of the
challenges is there are tracking devices
but they're usually not small enough to
be able to put on a migratory bird so
our thought was well if we could develop
a technology that could use information
within a single feather like information
in the DNA of the bird to track the
migratory movements then then we could
get information from every bird that
comes through a monitoring station if I
wanted to understand where my ancestors
were from I might take a DNA sample from
me and send it off to a genetic ancestry
service they would compare my DNA
against this huge database of DNA from
many many other people and be able to
identify that milah most likely ancestry
is largely Norwegian in a sense that's
what we're doing with the DNA found in a
single bird feather
it's like genetic ancestry mapping for
birds so here we have an American
robbing one of our genus cape species
this Robin yes I see you just Robin
migrates from the boreal forest in
Canada and parts of the US and goes as
far south in the winter as Mexico and we
also collect the feathers the tail
feathers that we use for genetic
analysis
[Music]
the reason why we collect these feathers
is because we can use the tip of the
feather right here which contains a
little bit of DNA to tell you which
migratory pathway this bird took and
where it winters and breeds so what you
have displayed here is the map for the
Wilson's Warbler showing the location of
the six populations each one goes to a
different wintering area for example the
Rocky Mountain population heads all the
way down to El Salvador and Panama using
their DNA we can follow their migratory
journey all we need is DNA from the tip
of a feather
now that the bird gene escaped project
is helping us understand where and how
birds move throughout the year we can
figure out the best ways to help them
survive in a changing world uncovering
the mysteries of bird migration may be
the key to protecting them
[Music]
[Music]